I'm Russell Cain comedian and podcast
host and I want to talk about the icon
Queen Victoria
born in Kensington Palace in 1819 her
father died when she was a baby leaving
Victoria to a lonely childhood where she
was groomed for the throne in 1837 aged
just 18 she became Queen she married her
cousin Prince Albert of saxe-coburg and
Gotha in 1840 Victoria fell in love with
Albert his Christmas trees and his
unusual down below jewelry Albert died
of typhoid fever in 1861 but not before
Victoria had squeezed out nine children
but guess what
turns out she was an awful mother she
was disgusted by babies and she resented
them keeping her away from her beloved
Albert all she wanted to do was spend
time with him she said this an ugly baby
is a very nasty object and the prettiest
is frightful when undressed until about
four months in short as long as they
have their big body and little limbs and
that terrible frog like action that's
from one of Victoria's letters it's a
not a fan and when her daughter Alice
got married it was according to one of
her letters the saddest day I can
remember she didn't want Beatrice to
marry either and when Beatrice got
engaged Victoria used notes to
communicate with her at mealtimes Wow
Victoria using notes instead of talking
to her as cold now I feel guilty because
I only ever dropped my momma text but
here's a positive you maybe weren't
expecting Victoria's Diaries reveal she
unashamedly loved sex she wrote my dear
Albert came in today from the rain he
looked so handsome in his white cashmere
breeches with nothing on underneath but
is it so shocking everyone loves sex
maybe we're just shocked because it's
coming from the woman we remembers the
grumpy old monarch in her morning
clothes
maybe we're just shocked because it's
coming from a woman for all her ramped
up sexiness though there's a rumor that
Victoria wouldn't pass laws on
lesbianism because she didn't believe it
existed
fun and games aside there's one dodgy
fact you cannot dodge when you're
talking about
Victoria she was the figurehead of the
British Empire while Victoria was Queen
one million people died unnecessarily in
the Irish potato famine Africa was
carved up by Europeans scrambling to
take advantage of the continents natural
resources there were concentration camps
in the Boer War men women and children
died in the 1857 Indian rebellion
perhaps worst of all millions of Indian
people died in famines while she was
Empress a couple of points in Victoria's
defense here and I promise I'm not just
pathetically groveling for a knighthood
first of all how involved could Victoria
have been in the colonies in real terms
she only had updates every couple of
weeks and she was surrounded by advisers
who did the nuts and bolts business of
administering the Empire something else
she once made a personal donation of two
thousand pounds to those starving during
the Irish potato famine so that would
suggest she wasn't entirely comfortable
with what her empire was doing and
remember she also condemned atrocities
on both sides during the Indian
rebellion and add to that she was firm
in her belief that there should be
religious freedom in India so can she be
held responsible you decide anyway
there's some facts do what you will
she was an emotionally repressed Nucky
addict who was also the figurehead of
the British Empire I'm off for a
piercing thanks for watching don't
forget to subscribe and click the bail
to receive notifications for new videos
see you again soon